retour en france quatre familles avaient
déposé hier une plainte contre l'évêque
de bayeux pour non dénonciation de viols
sur mineurs la sphère concerne en fait
un prêtre du diocèse l'abbé bissey en
prison depuis dix mois
l'évêque de bayeux lisieux se défend
aujourd'hui estime que les accusations
portées contre lui sont infondées magali
soeur pour mettre chevet il n'y a pas de
doute nous seigneur pican évêque de
bayeux connaissait les agissements de
l'un de ses frères rené bissey
aujourd'hui écroué soupçonné de viols et
d'agressions sexuelles sur quinze
adolescents afin de mettre à jour la
responsabilité de l'évêque l'avocat
ainsi que quatre familles de victimes
ont porté plainte hier pour non
dénonciation de viol sur mineur m chevet
affirme s'appuyer sur les témoignages
recueillis par le juge d'instruction
chargé de l'affairé bis et ce sont les
déclarations en qualité de témoin de
l'évêque lui même qui sont dans le
dossier et des déclarations de
du curé lui même et du vicaire général
qui tous disent que l'évêque a été mis
au courant dès le mois de décembre 96 où
il a reçu le curé lévesque l'a reçu à
nouveau en avril 97 pour s'entretenir de
ses difficultés
des accusations graves auxquels
monseigneur piquant a décidé de répondre
cet après midi lors d'une conférence de
presse en ce qui concerne les
accusations qui sont portées contre moi
dans des conditions étonnantes à travers
les médias suite au dépôt de cette
plainte
je tiens à réaffirmer avec clarté
qu'elle ne repose sur aucune réalité et
sont infondées enseignants pic en on
lira pas plus le procès de l'abbé bissey
qui devrait se dérouler prochainement
permettra peut-être de faire toute la
lumière sur cette affaire